[Music]
awesome thank you sam
and welcome everyone we're really
excited to
be uh to have this kind of pre-r studio
global session
uh so as another person from our studio
just
really glad to have you all here and
thanks for taking part of your week
to spend time with us as so i'm gonna
jump right in we only got a
a couple of minutes here um through the
kind of first thing i want to do is talk
a little bit about
conceptually how we think about data
science here at our studio
how that applies to pharma and then
we'll look at some of the exciting
updates that we're making
to support that conceptual framework
so data science we like to talk about it
as kind of a journey
you know you start out with this type of
presenting your screen so that it's full
screen
we can see the slides
thank you sorry about that yeah yeah no
no worries um so
yeah we so we think about data science
uh as a journey you know it's a very
iterative process as i'm sure you're all
aware
um it starts with a hypothesis
there's development and data involved in
that development
there's collaboration with others with
other teams other stakeholders and then
at the end is some type of deliverable
whether that's
automation or or a handoff to the fda
and so in pharma oftentimes what this
looks like
is something like early stage research
where you're developing that hypothesis
uh that might evolve into a full-blown
you know
experimental design and trial and then
into something like a report or
submission
uh it might look more like
manufacturing or marketing though those
are also key parts of the the pharma
journey
just determining some type of objective
and then iterating to decide if that was
the right objective
maybe coming up with models and doing
production scoring
and so there's a lot of different ways
this kind of journey can be realized
in the pharmaceutical space but what i
want to show you today is how we're
building tools to help
and where those tools fit into the
different parts of this journey
so on the top you have some major
updates
we've released in the last year to r
studios professional products
so in the development side uh we've done
a lot of work to ensure that our studio
scales
as your data in the richest of that data
grows
by allowing you to tap into things like
the cloud in the middle part there where
you're thinking about collaboration and
iteration we've done a lot of work in a
tool called our studio connect to help
you
dynamically share content and then
when it comes to hardening and
automation we've done a lot of work
in a project called package manager to
ensure
that whether you're doing an analysis in
r or in python whether it's using cran
or bioconductor
that you have the correct packages and
dependencies that you need
to be really certain that your work's
reproducible and reliable
so those are the things in blue those
are kind of all available today
as part of our studio team which is that
professional platform
for for doing data science that you'll
hear a little bit about this week
but on the bottom maybe more exciting
are some of the developments
specifically in the open source
community that we've partnered with
pharmaceuticals
the companies to kind of bring to really
support the workflows that you're doing
day to day so the big one that we're
going to look at today
is this new kind of reimagined r
markdown it's actually helpful
throughout
the journey of creating hypotheses
collaborating and sharing
so so we're going to spend some time
looking at that there's new packages
for the middle layer of work where
you're building models
specifically tidy models is going to be
a major part of the r studio conference
there's some work on shiny and our
markdown that's being done
one example of that work is the thematic
package
and then on the far end here something
that's really kind of specific to the
pharmaceutical space
is the work that we're doing around
validated submissions
and so one key element of that work is a
tool called gt
which is in our package for creating
tables and then
some work around validation and how
different platforms and tools that are
supportive of submission
can be validated so let's drill into a
few of those specifically
and then actually kind of look at what's
new
i'm so kind of going actually backwards
we'll start with those validation
documents i mentioned these are
documents that outline for packages that
are affiliated with our studio
so things like shiny and our markdown
tidy verse tidy models
as well as our studio team those
professional products
these documents outline how to think
about their software development life
cycle
for compliance so if your qa team has
ever asked you
you know how can we be sure that r is
producing kind of valid and correct
results that's a big question r
is a huge ecosystem some of the later
presentations today are going to
talk through how to think about
answering that question but we're
excited to announce some documents that
hopefully will just
answer that question for you
for these r studio affiliated packages
so be sure to check those documents out
and we won't read through them today
that date a lot more than the
couple minutes we have left the second
thing that i wanted to
kind of mention uh we talked about you
know
in the submission space it's really
critical that you have a package
management solution
and so our studio offers our studio
package manager as one option there
and we're excited to announce
bioconductor
as a new addition to that offering
and so to just kind of quickly show you
what that looks like
if you're using packages from
bioconductor you might be familiar with
this notion that bioconductor
does its releases about twice a year
and so package manager makes those same
releases
available to you there's instructions
for
inside the package manager for how to
set this up but one of the things we're
really excited about
is that previously there was kind of no
way to keep korean and bioconductor in
sync
and so if you're using our studio
package manager you can actually go
ahead
and keep those two things in sync
so that as you're backing up your
packages install packages from cram
you'll be guaranteed to get the right
results and i'm showing you today kind
of an internal version of this
but you can actually go to
packagemanager.rstudio.com
which is a free version of the package
manager service
and that bioconductor offering is
available there as well
so if you want to source bioconductor
packages as well
as a kind of frozen version of crayon
that will match the bioconnector release
and that's available to you today
so i know where we're going kind of in
rapid fire succession but the last thing
i wanted to talk a little bit about
was some of those changes in the open
source ecosystem
around our markdown and some of the
packages that work with our markdown to
create these beautiful documents
that you might be using internally or
for things like submissions
and so i'm going to talk about two
things an update to our markdown
and this package called gt and so we'll
kind of combine both of those into a
single demo
but before we hop into the id just to
give you a
understanding of gt it's a package
short for grammar of tables so it's very
similar to ggplot2 which is the grammar
of plots
and so what gt is all about is allowing
you to write really expressive and
flexible code for creating tables
and then take that code and use it to
render those tables
wherever you need them so the same code
can be used to create tables
that render to rtf for things like word
documents
or to render to html and so that's kind
of
the concept and i'll show you what that
package looks like and how you use it
inside of our markdown
so let me switch over to the rstudio id
you can this is all open source so you
can use the latest version of our studio
on your desktop or on a server
with these packages and basically the
workflow that you'll see
is similar to what we're looking at here
so i have some data this is just kind of
raw data inside of a data frame and to
turn that data into a table with gt
it's very similar to how you might
create a plot with gdplot2
so you start with this gt function and
then you
add pieces to get to the final
end result so in this case we're adding
some summary rows
we're adding a grand summary of
summaries and then we're telling gt
how to format the different text cells
so i'll actually go ahead and run this
code for you
and we can take a look at the output
so this is going to create for us a gt
table and by default that gt table is
going to be in html
so it's right here inside of our our
markdown document
and you can see kind of what i had
described
we start out with this data that's in a
table and then we're adding
summary rows we're adding a gram summary
which is this top row here
and then we're doing some formatting you
can see things like
footnotes are fully supported
different sections of tables are
supported you can
have custom formatting column headers so
a lot of flexibility
in creating the table just the way you
want
and you know that's already pretty
exciting but it gets even
better because with a single line of
code
you can take the same table that we've
created and save it to a different
output format
so if you need this table to exist
inside of a word document
you can create that rtf version of the
table that will then render
inside of word or inside of whatever
other
format formatting tool you want to use
so that's the really kind of exciting
update to gt
but i mentioned there was something else
so kind of the last thing i want to show
you
is this update to our markdown and the
way it works is
inside of the latest version of the ide
there's this new option
to essentially render the document as
you go
and so by clicking this kind of magic
button here
what i get is an interactive editor for
the
our markdown document so our code is
still here you can see our table is
still here
but as but i actually have kind of the
rendering of the r markdown
in real time and so why would you do
this
because it turns out it makes it really
easy to create
rich and powerful documents and so as an
example
i'll go ahead and insert another table
in this table we'll take a look at some
of the features that are available here
so as i type markdown that markdown is
going to be rendered in real time
i can even put in things like emojis
so there's full support for for
interactive editing
and you can even do things like render
latex
in mine you can see the preview shows up
and then the output shows up
so as you're writing it becomes a really
powerful way
to create and see exactly you know what
you're doing
but under the hood it's all still our
markdown so i can always
go back and forth if i wanted to to the
original
document that's just a plain text file
so we're excited about how all these
things together can can
hopefully help you in your day-to-day
work uh
achieve that data science journey and so
i'll end things there
this is just a little bit of a preview a
taste a sampling if you will
of what's to come both today and on our
studio conference so i'll hand things
back over to you sam thanks for having
[Music]
me
you